but first up he's an Academy Award
nominated actor who stars in the new
film LBJ out in theaters on November 3rd
I understand he's very personable Woody
Harrelson is
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
look at what did look at that they're
yelling at you this standing what did
you do to become so popular what do you
you're such a you're such a pain you
know if you don't hurt yeah it's nothing
to do with that yeah everybody wants to
be what he's friends and back in your
smoking days many were but let's talk
about your movie because I saw it it's a
terrific movie it's a great piece of
work on airport Lyndon Johnson I
understand you were reluctant to play it
because as many of us we didn't like
Vietnam yeah but all we could see with
Johnson but as you grow older as we both
are you see people and more I think
you're more forgiving right and you see
the good on the bed together Moorthy you
think well you know I wanted to work
with Rob Reiner because I think he's one
of our greatest directors and the you
know if you look at it's almost that
like Rob says it's almost the tale of
two presidents because there's the
Vietnam but then there's all this
important legislation that he passed
like the Voting Rights Act the Civil
Rights Act the head start he was great
yeah and he passed a lot of legislation
that you know you had to care to pass it
because it was you know helping poor
people like the war on poverty and so he
did a lot of great stuff and he was very
colorful guy very colorful and very I
think you caught this needy you know he
really wanted people to love him I feel
like that is maybe where you and the
character were able to because you're
like everybody to love you well you know
I don't give a [ __ ] are not cool
plainly plainly I don't give a [ __ ]
because we'd prefer it
I would prefer I would prefer everyone
agree with me but I'm not gonna I'm not
gonna say what I don't think just to
make them agree with me but but let's
get back to LBJ because that's what
we're here plugging I know you guys feel
this this guy I've been you know we've
been friends a long time very long time
long time we smoked a lot of joints
together and this guy has been
expressing what we've been feeling and
some of us afraid to express for so long
and I think that's why we appreciate him
[Applause]
[Music]
but okay let's go alright so thank you
very much says very sweet of you
I'd be Jesus I'm so I'm not like in bad
health
am i educate her but okay but like let's
talk about the vulgar part because we
have a vulgar president now and before
Trump Johnson was the standard of vulgar
like one of the first scenes in the
movie he's he's talking there's people
in the room important people that doing
government business and he's on the
phone to his tailor talking about who he
needs more room because he's talking
about how big his Johnson is yeah yeah
yeah how could you relate he wasn't
publicly vulgar like our president comes
right you know but he he did he was
father in private yeah but in our
current president you've had dinner with
Trump right didn't you have a dinner we
did have a dinner with them what was
that circumstance well / Jesse Ventura
and he said I'm you know he was what
year - mm and I was in New York and he
said would you come with me you know
Trump's gonna try to get me to be his
running mate on the 2004 ticket
Democratic ticket and he was a Democrat
then yeah yeah yeah so I went and it's
brutal it was brutal he said I never met
a more narcissistic man he talked about
himself the whole time it was changed a
lot
is you could see the standard he was
going to bear for it but I had to walk
out like halfway through smoke a joint
just to just select is that what you
told yourself about why you smoked the
joint you needed prompting let's talk
about that because it's funny you I mean
you have given it up for about a year
and a half now yeah and I think that's
great when we were in Hawaii last year
in solidarity I didn't want to tempt you
so I didn't do it around you when when
we were together but you were one of the
pioneers and I'm not gonna try to get
you back on the wagon at all but I just
want to show you no no I just want to
show you some pictures to reminisce I
mean that you were on our very first
show of real time in and and there we
are in my backyard in 2003 we're doing a
sketch remember we did a sketch about
smoking fire yeah we did that sketch
yeah and then okay but here's my here's
my point nobody here hears us this last
year in Hawaii after you had given up
pot and there we are with Jeff Ross and
you know you look you look okay but not
ecstatic and here we are the next night
at your house your porch that you live
on cuz it has no wall so you live in a
port okay I mean it's a beautiful view
it should be there's no walls it's a
porch okay so you know we look okay
there too but here's the year before
when we were completely big
just saying
I'm just concerned about your happiness
so let's look at it again not stoned
don't not stones stone but that's a
strong case that's about ready to fire
up a hitter now I
fire I didn't heard that but but you
haven't given up all your hippie ways
and that's great and and I'm always
amused by the great dichotomy that is
you because your scene is such a
laid-back I and you are I mean you are
as laid-back as it comes with as I know
you but you're obviously also a very
talented driven ambitious person you are
not in one not in - but you're in three
franchises you're in Hunger Games you
are and what's the magician one no I see
how you see me and you're in the eight
movie flattered to be able right that's
now how did the hippie how did this
laid-back guy get to be the guy in
Hollywood who's got a monopoly on being
in all the friends there's a little bit
of a personality and a be facade but I
am actually genuinely lazy as [ __ ] and I
could I mean I can get by doing nothing
you know you've seen me I can really get
by when was the last time you when the
last time you were when was the last
time you were home
January yeah because mr. lazy works his
ass off and we're the benefits cuz
you're leaving a great body of work and
this movie is part of it you should go
see it Woody Harrelson
[Applause]
last year